(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- All right, y'all.
When I find something on social media
that's super cute, I
wanna share it with you.
So this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
So you never know when
your kids might stumble
upon the next great idea.
Like who would've thought
that a four-year-old girl
bringing a chicken into her cheer routine,
which totally makes sense,
would take the internet by storm.
But indeed, it has.
- Five, six, seven, eight.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
(audience applauds)
- That Instagram post has 32.5 million
views and counting.
They are impressed by the chicken dance.
We have the young cheerleader
on the line right now,
along with her mama watching on KXXV.
Hi Fallon.
Hi Kendall.
(audience cheers)
- Hi Kelly.
Thank you so much for having us.
- Oh my gosh, you are so cute.
So Kendall, how did this happen?
- So we got chickens around the same time
she started cheerleading.
She begged for cheer for a long time.
We finally put her in
and then we got chickens too.
So she started spending lots
of time outside with them
and just combined the
two loves that she had.
And I turned around one day
and she was stunting her chicken.
I was like, that's actually
a really solid routine.
So I recorded it and posted it,
and that's when it just took off.
It was crazy.
- So what would Kelsey say to you,
do you think, Fallon?
- I love you.
(audience coos)
- Oh my God, you are so cute.
Ah, you make me wanna have babies.
Ah, but I don't wanna do that anymore.
Okay.
I love you, Fallon.
Your name is so awesome too.
Mama, way to go on the name.
That's such a cool first name.
So you have a new cheer, don't you?
Yeah?
Do you wanna show me your cheer?
- Yeah.
Let's show her.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Oh, there we
go. (audience laughs)
Yeah, dad!
- Five, six, seven, eight.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
(audience applauds)
- You are incredible, Fallon!
You're so cool.
Fallon, thank you for joining us.
Thank you, Fallon.
Thank you Kendall and Kelsey of course.
I'm liking y'all's post right now.
Look how gentle.
Oh my God, you're so cute.
Way to go, mama.
(audience coos)
Aw.
Okay, so that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go to pen of the
"Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to honor truly unstoppable people
that are just rad like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
How's that sound?
- Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you guys so much.
You have made me have the
greatest day ever, Fallon.
I love you, sweetheart.
Thank you for joining us
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Neil deGrasse Tyson, Bernie Taupin, Dylan,
and Alanis Morissette.
Y'all great day and if it's not,
try and change it.